with absolutely no hesitation or shame
whatsoever with no reservations at all
about what they were saying
fox news host maria bartoromo and former
trump economic adviser larry kudlow
suggested that joe biden might have such
serious dementia that he may not even
know where he is
he may not even know what he's signing
and that he may not even really be the
president that it actually might be
susan rice
who is a sort of shadow president
because joe biden is
so unaware of his surroundings almost
like a weekend at bernie's type
situation that they're suggesting now i
could say a lot of things in advance of
watching the clip
let's first look at the clip to orient
ourselves and then we'll talk
about it because it turns out president
biden
may be really given his first couple
weeks
uh the most left-wing president we've
ever seen
national review editor rich lowry wrote
a great column on this
his actions on spending and taxing and
regulating on immigration and fossil
fuels
and other cultural issues he may be the
most left-wing
i don't know whether he believes this
stuff i don't know whether he's an empty
vessel for the far left wing of his
party
but they are moving in the wrong
direction from day one
yeah well that's what i was going to ask
you who the heck is coming up with these
ideas
you know some people feel like susan
rice is running things does
does president biden understand what
he's signing into law here with these
executive orders
well that's a good question look i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna get into
you know is the alert or not alert he is
who he is
i knew joe biden very well a long time
ago but not for the last eight or ten
years
joe biden might be an empty vessel they
say who's coming up
with the things that biden is doing well
maybe it's susan
rice who's a shadow president running
the show
biden might not even understand the
things he's signing
is joe biden even alert and that when
you talk about alert you know it's a
reference to this medical term that's
used
x3 when you observe a patient they're
oriented in three ways
to person place and time it's like the
most basic
medical observation you can make about
someone
as to whether they have even the
cognitive capacity to know where
they are and when it is talking about is
joe biden
even alert so let's go through this in
pieces
when donald trump was president there
were such serious questions about his
cognitive state
the slurring the not realizing people
he's talking about are actually right in
front of him getting off air force one
and wandering off and having to be
brought back
by a secret service agent this sort of
glitching and and
verbal uh interruptions to his speech
that were very strange
um the talking about the oranges of an
investigation the citrus fruit of course
appearing to have no memory whatsoever
of things that happened shortly before
arguing with people combatively about
his cognitive state in bizarre ways and
numerous neurological and mental health
experts sounded the alarm about donald
trump
and we talked to some of them about it
and i would also ask those expert
experts when i would interview them
i would say what do you see with joe
biden because there are people on the
right talking about
joe biden dementia cognitive decline and
all of these experts said essentially
versions of the same thing which was
joe biden seems to have the type of
slowdown
that you see in more than 50 percent of
people when they approach
80 years old this is combining with joe
biden's
lifelong stutter to make him talk in a
particular way
but these not my opinion these experts
mental health and neurological experts
said they did not see the same things in
biden that they saw with trump that was
their opinion okay
having not personally examined trump nor
joe biden that was the opinion they came
away with
now i've been clear we shouldn't lie to
ourselves and others and say joe biden
is just
in joe biden in 2021 is just like he was
in 2012
when he ran circles around paul ryan in
the vice presidential debates if we were
to say that
it's obviously untrue and we lose
credibility 70 year old joe biden in
2012
um humiliated vice presidential
candidate paul ryan when romney was
running against barack obama joe biden
had a rapidity and a slickness and a
facility
when debating that he did not have in
2020 when debating donald trump there's
no question about it
this is common in people when they get
past the age of 75. now i'm i'm not
i'm not trying to be offensive we have
lots of folks in our audience in their
70s and their 80s
even in their 90s i'm thinking of our
friend sam in cambridge
vibrant energized in his 90s and a big
supporter of the show
but if you think about this on a bell
curve uh at age 78
lots of people are not as energetic as
they were earlier in life
this is the reality of humanity so
having without question conceded that
does joe biden know what he's signing
is susan rice actually the president
behind the scenes
this is ridiculous to be proposing on a
national cable news channel
for maria bartoromo and larry kudlow to
be doing it's outrageous and absurd and
of course
you simply have to see joe biden answer
questions from the press
as he's done half a dozen times in the
two weeks he's been president
to understand he knows what he's signing
he knows what he wants to do about this
or that
he can talk in detail about pandemic
response and who's on his staff and so
on and so
so forth you only need to watch five
minutes of that to know
that he understands the things that are
going on at least politically because
that's what he's talking about so
they lost the election they tried to
then steal it
and that failed and now they're
resorting to this and by the way
most americans like the things that
biden has done so far you know kudlow's
saying this is the furthest left
president ever
well maybe on paper that's actually true
but he hasn't really done that much yet
uh he's reversed some of the things
trump did and gotten us back to where we
were with obama
but these extreme leftist tendencies of
biden that are being claimed
so far he's not actually acted on any of
them if they exist and
and for the most part the country is
relatively pleased with joe biden 63
approval uh in general of joe biden
much higher than trump ever got at any
point during his presidency
69 approval for joe biden's coronavirus
response so far
80 support for joe biden's federal mass
mandate and on
and on and on so not only does joe biden
know what he's doing
most of the country likes what joe biden
is doing so far so just
absolutely wacky irresponsible stuff
there
on fox news one of our sponsors
is hydrant which is a delicious fruit
drink powder that you mix
into water for rehydration and they're
giving you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video